what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
okay i really think i have the audio
levels right this time but i'm not 100
sure so i need you to let me know in the
comments if this is right
anyone that's been following me knows
it's been a struggle i'm really sorry
i i think i got it so let me know in the
comments
don't forget to subscribe bring that
notification bell
and yeah i'm about to start the video
it's titled she cheated here's what you
do
[Music]
i actually i've always forget that i put
my speed on fast when i watch by myself
i i have a question um or if you don't
that's fine we can skip you
if if you were to be in a serious
relationship okay
would you and and your your girlfriend
were to cheat on you would you prefer
her cheat on you with another man
or a woman and why
aren't there some guys that don't think
it's cheating if it's with a girl
it's kind of weird to me all right
damn he's beating me today
uh uh there is she's done
she's absolutely done but like how would
you feel
if she cheated on you with a man and how
would you feel if she cheated on you
there was no feeling because it's over
period
here's the thing with women
men have i agree if somebody cheats on
you you should go
man or woman you should go it's not
worth staying in a relationship where
now you have to
one be insecure and two
you know second guess yourself and like
wonder what they're doing to bring a lot
to the table
to attract women we have to be typically
taller earn more money
have confidence be attractive be fit to
some degree whatever may be but
even the most average woman has above
average standards of the man that she's
going to deal with
so women look for superior men however
don't date with that same strategy where
i need a superior
men are totally happy dating women below
them
now obviously that comes at a cost right
the women
that deal with a man don't have to bring
as much to the table
men are very simple since the beginning
of time be attractive
non-combative don't give me a hard time
maybe cook maybe clean make a sandwich
in silence whatever it is right we can
make as many
sandwich jokes as we want but the point
of the matter is this
men have to bring far more to the table
to get sexual access to women than women
have to bring to the table to get sexual
access to men
so therefore each of the things that a
woman brings to the table
is extremely important and the number
one thing
that a woman has to bring to the table
when she deals with a man in any type of
real relationship it's gotta be loyalty
is
monogamy and fidelity yeah so loyalty
essentially
she can't run around [ __ ] other dudes
you had one job
and you [ __ ] it up the problem is that
women want to play
male roles when it's convenient to them
but they also want to play female roles
when it's convenient to them
you [ __ ] a bunch of girls so i should be
able to [ __ ] a bunch of guys but on the
other hand you need to treat me like a
lady
and that's the problem with modern day
women and feminism in general it
absolves women of traditional
responsibilities
and gives them modern standards but they
still expect meant to be traditional men
and i look at it like if you expect me
to be a traditional man
be taller than you make more money than
you'd be successful etc bring all these
things to the table you better not suck
anyone else's dick
the problem is that most guys don't like
saying this because if you say this
you're labeled a misogynist toxic
an [ __ ] a jerk or whatever it is
i would say if you're the type that's
going to cheat on somebody like
man or woman if you're the type to like
actually be in love with somebody and
step out on that
like that says more about your character
um i don't really see a difference
between men and women cheating i know
this is
unpopular in the manner sphere but if
either one does it
like i genuinely i think that's a
reflection on you and your character
this podcast the reason why we're
growing so fast because we're saying
what a lot of guys want to say
we don't want no [ __ ] hoes and we're
not going to take them seriously we
might have sex with you guys
we ain't going to commit to you is just
that if you say things like this
you know you're gonna get canceled so i
would say to to answer your question i
just had to
give you the background of why i believe
that no i understand um
to give you the background there is no
how i feel about her cheating on me with
a man or woman it's done
she's dead to me now
uh so i agree you shouldn't tolerate
that feeling for me uh from a girl
i'm dealing with men and women uh to me
like is over because
if you're gonna go behind my back with
somebody else obviously you're not that
into me because uh
i feel like when a girl really really
likes you or she's into you she won't
even
do it act or like even do anything crazy
that'll make you
uh leave her because at that point it's
like is it worth losing
what i got at home for this guy our girl
so uh
overall i just feel like by teachers
okay um i don't necessarily disagree the
only part i would say i disagree with on
freshman's fit is they think there's
like a big difference between men and
women doing it
um and i would say either way like i i
wouldn't want to be in a relationship
where oh my gosh i forget the camera's
over here i wouldn't want to be in a
relationship where that happens so let
me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell i'll talk to you
guys
next time